Russia says two drones have been
intercepted and destroyed in the defense
Ministry in the capital Russian
officials accused Ukraine of an
attempted terror attack on Moscow the
drones reportedly struck non-residential
buildings the mayor says there was no
serious damage or casualties
well for more on this let's go to Euler
sharp of Oliver in Moscow now you know
what more is Russia saying about this
yeah indeed two Moscow Central districts
were attacked by two drones were hit a
business center the other one fell in
close proximity to the building and the
ministry of Defense Moscow May Sergey
sabyanin announced a drone stroke two
non-residential buildings as you
mentioned no casualties or serious
damage were reported currently there are
many ambulance and police cars in the
center of Moscow also the mayor's office
said that traffic along two major
Avenues close to the place of the
incidence has temporarily have
temporarily been suspended Russia's
Ministry of Defense blamed Ukraine for
that tag saying quote it was an attend
by the Kiev regime to carry out a
terrorist attack both uavs were jammed
by electronic warfare systems and then
crashed and local residents reported
multiple cases of broken glass in the
windows due to the uav's attacks
okay we leave it there you the shop of
Oliver thank you for that update live
for us